hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll today's big
idea is a somewhat tricky one it's one
that has received both attention and
also a little bit of controversy within
physics as well as in philosophy and
that is the idea of emergence emergence
in the sense of what we might call a
higher level theory emerging from a
lower level one and I'm gonna use a lot
of words like what we might call in this
video because some of these ideas are
not agreed on or at least the way to
talk about them or is not agreed on so
I'm gonna try mostly to stick to things
that are indisputably true rather than
diving into the most controversial
aspects of the subject but be aware that
out there there are people who use the
words in slightly different meanings and
disagree with each other nevertheless
this is a topic of emergence that
deserves its place in the biggest ideas
in the universe because it's part of
this program we're doing in the most
recent couple videos of mapping matching
the micro physics the fundamental
physics of quantum field theory or
whatever the ultimate theory of
everything turns out to be to the
observed world that we see you know
remember we talked about probability and
things like that the fact that we're not
Laplace is diamond so now we can get a
little bit more deeply into what can we
do given that we are not Laplace is
diamond can we nevertheless talk
usefully about the universe and that's
where emergence really is crucial it's
not just optional right it's really
really crucial so we absolutely have to
face up to this idea so let me just do a
little bit of explaining what where the
idea of emergence comes from in science
the idea again these are gonna be the
ideas that i'm gonna assume are true for
the rest of this video you may disagree
that's okay you may always disagree
there is only one reality and this might
seem like a strange thing for someone
who believes in the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics to
say but for many worlds are for never
ready in the the reality is the
multiverse it is all the worlds all at
once okay so this is not talking about
branches of the wavefunction this is
talking about the global wave function
of the universe
so where's assuming there is some
thing called reality there's not that
many people who think that there's not
anything called reality but there are
plenty of people who think that the job
of science is not to describe reality
they distinguish between what may or may
not exist as reality and our
observational outcomes when we look at
the world and they say the job of
science is just to describe what we see
when we look not to describe what is
really there so I am NOT in that camp
so I don't even know how to talk that
language so I'm going to assume there's
something called reality that we're
trying to describe but there are
multiple many many many theories that
can describe reality all at once so the
multiple theories describing reality in
different useful ways so the idea is
that you can sort of capture different
in fact let's say different accurate
ways it's not just useful useful as a
little bit weaker than I want to say you
can capture different aspects of reality
using different theories of physics so
just to give away the game right away
the classic example is the one we
already talked about last time with
atoms and molecules and kinetic theory
being some kind of attempt at a
fundamental theory in 19th century
physics and then the emergent theory is
a theory of gases or fluids or whatever
thermodynamics okay thermodynamics fluid
mechanics etc so you don't need to know
all the details about all the molecules
to nevertheless have a good theory of
the world so the idea here is what we're
saying here is that the multiple
theories we have in mind would be the
kinetic theory of the atoms molecules
and also the fluid dynamics theory all
by itself
so you can derive fluid dynamics from
atoms and molecules but you knew fluid
dynamics first right or let's put it
this way I don't forget about whatever
that historically actually happened you
don't need to know about atoms and
molecules to have fluid mechanics okay
it's an independent autonomous way of
talking about the world that is accurate
in a certain regime and not in others
okay and that's what I want to say here
these theories can be
different theories that can be different
already said that the theories should
agree in overlapping domains so the idea
here is that there is something called
the domain of applicability of the
theory when you have the fluid dynamics
description if you know that there is
also a more comprehensive atomic kinetic
theory description you don't expect the
fluid dynamics description to tell you
anything in the regime when you only
have one molecule in your system right
it's becomes true in the limit when you
have many many many molecules so there
are different domains one molecule many
many many molecules in some domains the
theories are either going to be
completely inapplicable or they will
disagree but when they are accurately
describing reality there is a regime in
which they overlap and then they agree
with each other so that's the basis you
know that's based on this fact that we
think that there is a reality so where
the theories overlap and are supposed to
be valid they both better or they all
better be describing reality okay and to
be honest usually you can talk to a
scientists a lot and they will very
rarely use the word reality they're not
against it but they know better they
know that they don't know what reality
is they assume it's out there most of
them but well we know what we have our
models and what we have our experimental
data and we have some interplay between
those we like to think that our models
get better better at capturing reality
but to a large extent when we talk about
emergence in this way and we talk about
the relationship of some higher-level
theory to some lower-level theory we're
talking about relationships between
theories themselves rather than
relationships between theories and
reality because who knows what that is I
mean the relationship is we capture some
of it but who knows how much of it who
knows what captures the rest etcetera so
the basic picture that we have to do to
say the same thing we just said but to
say it in pictures emergence the usual
way it's used will be a little bit more
careful later on but the notion of
emergence is a
and again the usual way higher level and
that usually is taken to mean
macroscopic large scale many moving
pieces going on underneath theory
emerges emerging from a lower-level
microscopic theory and you could also
say fundamental instead of microscopic
that annoys people but none of these
words are exactly right to mean
fundamental makes it sound like it's
more important which is just false okay
just because a theory describes what
goes on at a more comprehensive way
doesn't mean it's more important right
if you want to get from here to the moon
Newtonian gravity is more important than
quantum gravity okay or even more
important than general relativity it
helps get you there in an efficient way
so fundamental is doesn't it have
exactly the right connotations
microscopic isn't right either because
the theory is supposed to be true at
every level it's just that it becomes
important at tinier levels
I once tried to have a campaign to
replace the phrase fundamental physics
by the phrase elementary physics
elementary in the sense of basic like
you know the the stuff out of which you
could potentially derive everything else
but also unlike fundamental elementary
sounds a little deflationary right it
sounds like oh it's just a simple stuff
it's not the you know the big hard stuff
no one agreed with my proposal though so
I didn't really catch on so higher level
and lower level or another way of saying
the same thing you just got to remember
which is higher and which is lower so
the way we do that is we say you know
here is reality again this is something
that I'll mention but most scientists
can get away without talking about and
then there's some microscopic theory by
which we mean the theory that purports
to be comprehensive as comprehensive as
it can be describing reality and it
might not do the whole thing so let me
let me see if I can do this I'm going to
take this ellipse
I am gonna duplicate it so I get exactly
the same ellipse they'll put it down
there and the idea is that this region
of reality is described by this theory
okay but then there's some smaller
region of reality which is like a subset
you then again this is just the usual
picture we'll try to be more careful
later but usually when you have the gas
versus the you know the fluid dynamics
description versus the atoms description
there is a smaller domain of
applicability for the gas description in
principle you could always describe
what's going on in a box of gas just in
terms of the atoms and molecules might
be very impractical but that's what
Laplace is deeming would do so there's
some strictly smaller theory the macro
theory that describes the macroscopic
world do the same trick here put that
down there and then say here is the
region of reality oops I should do this
down here also should my region of
reality what did I do oh my goodness I
know where that came from
I should just delete this video I'll
leave it in for the video people like it
when I do silly things in the real time
in the video there we go okay so there
is some macro theory that is a subset of
the micro theory and therefore describes
a smaller part of reality and hopefully
ideally all these are going to be well
understood all these relationships and
so this is the emergent theory in this
case that's roughly speaking what we
what we mean now the reason why I have
to be so weaselly worried about this and
keep you know saying not everyone agrees
is because again to preview a little bit
there are people who think that there is
an important difference between a theory
that is microscopic and a theory that is
comprehensive so what is implicit in a
lot of these discussions of emergence is
that the microscopic theory literally
describes tiny little
cases that somehow come together to form
big pieces in the macroscopic theory
that's kind of what happens when you go
from atoms to a box of gas but it's not
what happens in quantum mechanics for
example where things are much more
subtle and maybe it's not what happens
in things like consciousness you could
talk about whether there's a theory of
consciousness that emerges from a theory
of neurons in the brain and there people
are less happy some people are less
willing to think that a microscopic
theory of neurons could in principle
describe macroscopic consciousness
that's a more contentious topic anyway
but anyway this is this is the basic
picture that we have in mind let's get
into some details let's give you some
examples so the classic example that we
already mentioned is atoms or particles
emerging into gases and to look up
whether it's just 1s or 2's in the
middle gases it's 1s I've typed that
word a million times in my life but
there you go
so the more microscopic theory is the
theory of atoms or molecules or
particles or whatever and you have some
point in gamma space or you have
endpoints in Moose Pass and the language
that we used last time so you have some
phase space variables X I P i okay the
position and momentum of every single
particle in the gas in the box of gas or
whatever and then you have some theory
up here of the gas or the fluid whatever
it's gonna be
and there the language you speak is a
completely different language and that's
the important point here you talk about
the density the pressure the temperature
the velocity field of the gas and so
forth so in this case there's a very
very special case because here you can
actually derive the higher level
macroscopic rules there's literally a
map you can construct from the
microscopic situation to the macroscopic
situation so I'm not gonna do that in
any detail but you know basically how it
works the density I know that you might
not be familiar with the Greek letter
Rho being used for density but that's
what we used the density comes
from the number density of particles of
atoms times the mass per particle so the
density here we really mean the mass
density and these are both things you
can work out if you know where you are
in phase space for all the particles
you've got how many particles there are
in a region and what their masses are
right you know that the temperature
comes from the average kinetic energy of
the particles comes from means it's
proportional to and the proportionality
depends on details about you know how
much they spin how many dimensions
you're in things like that
the pressure comes from you know the
force across an imaginary barrier so we
mean there is imagine the in your box of
gas you put down a little wall and then
you said well I have a bunch of
particles here they're gonna bump into
the wall and then careen off and I can
figure out the total force there if that
wall were there that's what the pressure
is the pressure is how much force would
be exerted on you if you put your hand
in there okay so you can calculate all
those from these quantities that you're
given in the microscopic theory but
that's unusual that is not necessary in
any sense it is far more common that you
discover the macroscopic theory
completely independently of knowing the
microscopic theory and that by the way
is number one amazing the fact that
that's how nature works and number two a
perfectly good reason why you need
things other than fundamental physics in
your life okay this is the fundamental
lesson of a very famous article written
by Philip Anderson Nobel Prize winning
physicist who passed away recently he
wrote an article in the early 70s for
physics today I think it was called more
is different and the point of the
article was it's when you have a
collection of many things atoms or
electrons or whatever and you consider
their collective behavior there are
things that happen that in practice you
never would have guessed
knowing what the individual constituents
were there is collective behavior that
gives rise to new kinds of phenomena
whether it's super conductivity or phase
transitions or whatever in principle
maybe you could have taken the
microscopic picture put it on a computer
or giving it to Laplace's daemon and
figure out exactly what happened but
there's a way of talking about what
happens purely at the higher level that
gives you some amount of insight that is
irrelevant that is that is independent I
should say of what's going on at the
lower level that's why I Anderson says
it more is different now there's an
ongoing controversy between different
camps of people about whether or not you
could in principle put the microscopic
theory on a computer and simulate it or
whether or not it's so different once
you get to the macroscopic level that
you couldn't even do that and we'll talk
a little bit about that later on what I
really wanted to say so the two things I
want to say about this picture right
here are number one in principle there's
this relationship between the micro
theory and the macro theory it might be
impossible or difficult to derive but in
principle it's there but number two you
notice in this case that the
relationship between the micro theory
and macro Theory changed the very nature
of what we said exists okay in the micro
theory you said I what is this thing
what is this box of what you have a box
of what what is it and you say well it's
a collection of particles they have
certain masses certain positions certain
velocities but if you were speaking the
vocabulary of the emergent higher-level
theory someone says a box of what you
say oh it's a gas with a certain
temperature and pressure it's a
completely different set of words and
concepts that you're using and that's a
kind of the magic of emergence there
you're describing the same thing in two
very different ways and we're gonna get
pretty deep into exactly how different
that can be but so this is a very common
example but let me give you another
example which is equally true and
relevant but kind of sneaks under the
radar a little bit so let's call this
the sneaky example of emergence and that
is center of mass motion by which we
mean when you talk about you know we
already mentioned going to the moon in a
spacecraft
talk about celestial mechanics the earth
going around the Sun going around the
earth whatever if you want to solve that
if you're you know people do this you
want to solve for the motion of the
earth through the solar system over
millions of years okay so you need to
account not only for the moon and the
earth but also all the other planets and
even like the shape of the of the earth
a little bit but to a very very very
good first approximation you just need
to know as far as the earth is concerned
it's center of mass and the velocity of
that center of mass so you have the
whole earth here earth for example and
of course the earth is made of many many
particles roughly ten to the fiftieth
particles in the earth depending on how
you count I'm not sure why I think
that's true there's some number embedded
in my brain in my memory but in a recent
video I mixed up lithium and beryllium
so you shouldn't really trust what's
embedded to my brain but there's a
center of mass for all those particles
and you can figure out where that is and
then there is a velocity or a center of
mass momentum also so you have X center
of mass and P center of mass and one of
the very crucial things that Isaac
Newton himself figured out was that in
terms of Newtonian gravity that's all
you need if the objects are spherical
you don't need all of the information
about the individual particles you can
boil the information you need down to
where the center of mass is and then
from there you can get the orbit of the
earth to very very high approximation
not perfectly because you know there are
tidal forces the fact that the moon
orbits the earth which you know is true
and you can get again a good
approximation to that both from the
center of masses of both of them but the
moon also gradually moves away from the
earth and that's because of tidal
friction between the moving the rotating
earth and moon and to understand that
you need to go beyond the center of mass
approximation but this is a really
really good approximation and it's an
example of emergence because the theory
that you're using to describe the earth
going around the Sun is a theory of a
point
a point mass with three coordinates for
its position and three momentum right
that's not what the earth actually is
but it's a really good emergent
description of it so in both of these
cases we have a situation where there is
a many to one map when you do that
emergent description from micro to macro
well I mean by that is for the gases up
here if you're and this is you be
familiar with this from the entropy that
we talked about in the last video given
the density as a function of space and
the temperature as a function of space
and the pressure etc there are many
microscopic points in phase space that
would look like that macroscopically up
to some you know tolerance or precision
or error bar
likewise given the center of mass of the
earth and the center of mass momentum of
the earth there are many arrangements of
the individual atoms and molecules that
make up the earth that would give you
that so there's a many to one map and
that is the phenomenon we call coarse
graining so both of these examples of
emergent phenomena are ones where coarse
graining plays a role but that's
actually not it's not necessary that
I'll talk a little bit about what that
means what I want to what I want to
emphasize here is that when we talked in
the last video at entropy coarse
graining played an important role in
Boltzmann's definition of entropy right
the entropy was the logarithm of the
number of microstates in a coarse grain
macro state but that was just
descriptive of the configuration that we
were looking at right so when we talked
about the evolution of the state we sort
of talked about it microstate by
microstate we said that it's probable
that most microstates will do this or
that this emergence thing is a deeper
claim because this is saying that not
only can we coarse grain but when we
coarse grain so when we map all of the
microstates of the earth into is just a
center of mass that leaves us enough
information to predict what's going to
happen next there is an autonomous
theory of the coarse-grained States
themselves we didn't need to make that
claim
entropy we just said well there's some
macroscopic observables and that's what
we're gonna keep track of here we're
making the much stronger claim that that
coarse graining that comes from
macroscopic observables or whatever or
give us enough information to make a
predictive theory about what's going to
happen next that's kind of an amazing
fact and that's why merchants is so
awesome also by the way I forget how
much to say this now yeah I'll see you
later there's another amazing fact that
I will say later good so let me contrast
this both of these cases where there's a
many to one map there are also cases
where just a one to one map okay so
there's there are also cases of limits
rather than coarse graining and this is
does this count as emergence when you
take a limit of a theory and get another
theory I don't know who cares
I don't I don't really care what the
official definition is this is a related
concept and you should be clear when one
concept is relevant versus another one
so for example what I mean by this I
mean by this well let's just do the
example and I'll be clear so consider
general relativity you're all experts in
general relativity because you've seen
the video called gravity where we talk
about which n relativity says those of
you who might not have those of you
living a thousand years from now going
through the archival footage first look
at the video on curvature on geometry
and topology then you can do the video
on general relativity and general tivity
theory of gravity and curved space-time
and it's sort of a generalization of
special relativity in some sense because
special relativity is a set of rules
that forces there to be no gravity okay
and the rules of special relativity
gravity is not there space-time is
completely flat so we can think of
special relativity as a limit of general
relativity where we turn gravity off you
can do this formally you can send
Newton's constant to zero the Newton's
constant of gravity capital G right if
it were zero then gravity wouldn't exist
and you wouldn't have any curvature of
space-time so you can you can take Jenna
Relativity as you move this up here a
little bit and take a limit where you
turn gravity off and you can get special
relativity there's a different limit you
can take because sometimes you have like
in the solar system what if you wanted
to calculate the precession of mercury
okay like Einstein actually did you
don't need the full-blown apparatus of
all of general relativity you don't need
where about gravitational waves or
something like that so there's an
approximation you know even further than
that what if you just wanted to
calculate the motion of a rocket going
from here to the moon what do you really
need is Newtonian gravity right that's
all you need you could do it in general
relativity but it's a whole bunch of
formalism and math and Greek indices you
don't really that are not helpful or
necessary so what you want to say is
that in a certain regime Newtonian
gravity is just as good as general
relativity and that regime is formalized
by taking a limit the limit is gravity
exists to get Newtonian gravity can't
get rid of gravity entirely but gravity
is weak okay so when gravity is weak you
can't have things like black holes or
you can't have things like the Big Bang
or anything like that but this is not
enough because even when gravity is weak
there is things that Newton's theory
cannot handle namely anything moving
near the speed of light like a
gravitational wave for example likewise
if the planets in the solar system we're
moving close to the speed of light
relativistic effects would be important
in Newtonian gravity would not be enough
so the Newtonian gravity limit of
general relativity is both when gravity
is weak and velocities are much much
less than the speed of light when
particles are moving slowly and gravity
is weak you can show you can by my text
book in general relativity space-time
and geometry and we will derive
Newtonian gravity from general
relativity in this limit and then you
can sort of combine these limits you can
take special relativity and take the
limit where velocities are much much
less than the speed of light or you
could take Newtonian gravity and turn
gravity off entirely
and in both cases what you would just
get is Newtonian mechanics
non-gravitational Newtonian mechanics so
this is a nice easy to understand case
where certain comprehensive theories
have limiting cases and it's exactly the
how they fit together in exactly this
way right the comprehensive theory
general relativity has a wider domain of
applicability than special relativity or
Newtonian physics but the difference is
in the examples I gave earlier there was
coarse graining right we were forgetting
information whereas these are
fine-grained limits these are one-to-one
maps one-to-one between situation and
general relativity a situation general
relativity uniquely defines a situation
in Tonie gravity for example okay it's
not that there are many many different
little microscopic pieces moving around
in general relativity that all look the
same to Newtonian gravity it's just that
there are regimes where generality works
and Newtonian gravity doesn't and works
it's important here because Newtonian
gravity still exists in those regimes
right like you can take as much energy
density or mass density as you want and
squeeze it into a ball and say what
would the description of that be in
Newtonian gravity if the general
relativistic description was a black
hole that means that Newtonian gravity
doesn't work there but it still says
something ray still exists so the theory
itself if I guess what I mean is that
oftentimes the macro theory exists or
says things in a wide region they're
just not true things they're just not
things that actually describe what is
happening in the world so you get both
of these kinds of behaviors you can get
emerging theories both from a
many-to-one kind of coarse graining map
or just one-to-one fine-grained maps in
the case of limits so if we want to
classify all the different ways that
theory can emerge at higher levels
versus lower levels in this case by the
way in these limiting cases it's not
even clear people would use a higher
level versus
lower level language but sometimes they
would and again I don't care what the
language is that they would use so
basically there are two questions that
you want to ask about maps between
theories that will help you sort of
understand what's going on one is do
they have the same structure or ontology
as the philosophers would say ontology
is just the set of things right the
objects the notions the ideas out of
which the theory is constructed so if
the structures are the same then we can
call them homeo structural same
structure and if they're not then they
would be hetero structural and we saw
examples of that right the center of
mass motion was the same kind of theory
it was just Newtonian mechanics of
positions and velocities just in a much
smaller number of variables so the
structure was the same whereas when we
went from the atoms to the gas the
structure was something completely
different and the other question which
we all just which we've just said are
the maps one to one or many to one we
draw this as an arrow and if it's one to
one then we say that the maps are
fine-grained and if it's many to one
then they're coarse-grained
and there are examples of all of these
right so you get two questions you have
two answers each is a little 2x2 grid
and we can do that we can we can draw
the grid and we can fill it in so here
is homeo structural same kind of
structures same ontology or hetero
structural and then there are
fine-grained maps and then there are
coarse grained maps okay so what is it
an example of a fine-grained map that is
homeo structural well what you're saying
here is that one state in a theory Maps
on to one state of another theory and
the kinds of states are the same kind of
thing so in other words nothing really
changed right but maybe you have a good
theory and a bad theory or maybe you
have a theory that is accurate in a wide
variety of circumstances and another
theory that just claims to be a
simplification in some sense so
basically what you have in this in this
box up here are theories that are just
simplifications of bigger theories not
really this is where the word emergence
would rarely be used I think in this
particular case but for example you know
any of the oldest Fira kakao examples
that we talked about you know
frictionless planes a ball rolling down
a frictionless plane that's described
within Newtonian mechanics with the same
ontology of points in phase space and
forces and F equals MA and so forth
you've just decided to ignore friction
right so you haven't changed the
structure and you haven't changed the
number of different states in the theory
or anything like that you just
simplified your life so that's that's
the thing you can do but it's not very
highbrow in terms of what do you mean by
emergence for the homeo structural same
structure but coarse-grained well then
we have center of mass motion right
that's a very good example for different
structures fine grained well general
relativity mapping on to Newtonian
gravity the Newtonian limit of GR
[Music]
it's a different kind of structure
because general relativity says what the
world is is a curved Varenne Sein
space-time manifold that's what it says
it is right and Newtonian gravity
doesn't say that Antonian gravity says
that space and time are absolute and
there's a gravitational potential field
on top of that which obey certain
equations the inverse square law for
example so the language that you speak
has become different even though it's
describing the same set of things in the
domain where Newtonian gravity works and
the biggest sort of you know most
interesting box here is when you coarse
grain and have a different structures so
for example when atoms are coarse
graining to give you a guess or fluid
description so all of these actually
happen which is a good thing to keep in
mind when you're debating different
examples or aspects of emergence and so
with that little classification scheme
in mind let me mention a couple of
features this thing I mention two quick
features that you keep in mind one is
the thing that I said I was going to
tell you which is an amazing fact appear
with you know the earth being
describable in terms of its center of
mass not quite sure exactly how to
phrase this best what I wrote down here
was emergence is precious so what I mean
by this is when you do this example of
taking the earth with 10 to the 15th
particles and describing in terms of its
center of mass you know you're saying
every particle lives in a six
dimensional phase space right so I
didn't you know get did not only getting
the order of magnitude right here but
the phase space for the earth is
something like 10 to the fifty or 1758
one dimensional and you're saying I can
describe its motion to a good
approximation by appointing a six
dimensional phase space so what I'm
doing by this coarse graining procedure
is I'm throwing away a lot of
information I could write down the
positions and velocities of every
particle in the earth in the
center-of-mass frame of the earth right
so I could give you what the center of
mass is and I could give you the
positions and velocities of all the
particles relative
to that center of mass and what I'm
telling you here is that none of those
relative positions in velocities matter
at all I can ignore them I can throw
them away once I've told you what the
center of mass is doing that's all I
need to know and that's what's extremely
precious that's what I'm trying to get
at here because the idea that I can take
some system described by an enormous
number of variables an enormous number
of degrees of freedom and not tell you
what the overwhelming majority of
degrees of freedom are doing is amazing
it's not generic it's not robust it
doesn't usually work just imagine I told
you you know so what I'm what I'm saying
is for that example we've thrown away
you know all but one in ten to the 50th
of the pieces of data okay but there are
simple examples where I throw away half
the data so I'm throwing away much much
less and I get nothing what if I've told
you the position of every particle in
the earth so that's way more information
but I haven't told you the velocity of
any of the particles in the earth okay
tell me how the earth moves you can't do
it at all you know nothing about how
it's moving even though I giving you
enormous ly more information if you get
right down to it if I give you the
position of every particle in the earth
and the velocity of every particle
except for one what can you tell me
about what the Earth's gonna do next
nothing literally nothing and you say
well no I think the Earth's probably
gonna move over here but it's always
possible that that one particle has a
momentum in the other direction bigger
than the comfort total momentum of all
the other particles right strictly
speaking if I didn't give you that
momentum I can tell you nothing so the
idea that you can throw away information
an enormous amount of information all
but a tiny little sliver of information
and still get a theory that predicted
that predicts accurately what's gonna
happen next is enormous ly special and
non-generic and precious okay it
reflects something real and important
about the nature of reality that such
descriptions exist at all there's no
theorem that says when I have a theory
described by ten to the fiftieth degrees
of freedom there exists a description
while
we need to keep track of a handful of
them and I can figure out what's going
to happen next that is very that's very
weird in some sense right I don't know
why it's true and I mean maybe you can
argue for if I don't think it's anything
we understand at a very deep level so
this relates to what Daniel Dennett
calls real patterns I did a podcast with
Dan Dennett if you want to talk if you
want to see his viewpoints on this the
point being that sometimes when people
talk about these coarse-grained
high-level descriptions they will give
you the impression that what they really
are conveniences right it's easier to
deal with this coarse-grained
approximate description and often they
want to do that because they want to
question or undermine the idea that the
higher level things are real right
tables and chairs aren't real just atoms
are real or something like that
but Dennis says no the fact that there
is this pattern the fact that you can
ignore almost all the data and still
find out what's going to happen next in
the life of this macroscopic system is a
real objective fact about the system so
these higher level things deserve to be
called real they they're they have an
ontology of their own there really is
the center of mass of the earth
there really is a table and a chair even
though those are higher-level emergent
phenomena okay
the other thing I wanted to say is
there's a phenomenon called universality
or it's called different things in
different contexts in a sort of
computation or consciousness context it
would be called substrate independence
and the idea here is that if you go back
up to the gas okay you got some atoms
you can have this gas you can derive the
properties of gas from the atoms but as
I said you could have found the laws of
fluid mechanics without knowing anything
about atoms in fact you can have two
gases
whose you know important qualities are
the same their densities their pressures
and the equations governing their
motions are the same but they're made of
different atoms right so you can have
the same microscopic theory you're sorry
you can have two different microscopic
theories giving you the same macroscopic
behavior the same emergent behavior in
other words knowing what happens at the
emergent level is not enough to fix what
happens at the microscopic level you
were familiar with this actually from
when we talked about the renormalization
way back when we talked about the fact
that you know compare this to the idea
of ultraviolet completions what we said
was you know in renormalization theory
we admit that we don't know what's going
on at very small length scales very high
energies so we say but that's okay we
can find a theory that only applies to
the low way to the low energies and long
wavelengths the infrared theory and
there can be more than one possible
ultraviolet completion that gives us the
same infrared behavior so this is a good
news bad news situation as is so often
the case I mean by the way in the in the
computation or consciousness world the
substrate independence is the idea that
consciousness or thought should be
thought of as a process and that process
can be instantiated in neurons but it
could equally well be instantiated in
silicon you know in a computer or
something like that and again now when
you put it that way people might be more
reluctant to sign on some people are all
for it and some people are more
skeptical but the good news is we can
say useful things about the macroscopic
world without knowing the theory of
everything
right we can fly a rocket to the moon
without knowing the complete theory of
quantum gravity because we can get an
emergent theory that is very very
accurate without knowing the microscopic
one the bad news is we can know the mic
the emergent theory and still not know
the microscopic theory so this is why as
we mentioned in the renormalization
video it's hard to get data at something
like the Large Hadron Collider that is
relevant to quantum gravity because
that's in a regime which is just not
described like there's many things that
could potentially be going on
the Planck scale where quantum gravity
is important that would lead to the same
behavior at the Large Hadron Collider or
at observable everyday energies so this
the potential existence of universality
many microscopic theories giving the
same macroscopic behavior that's a
problem in some sense for physicists it
gets it gets in the way sometimes but
it's there it's real so we got to deal
with it there you go
okay so for the rest of this video I'm
not done yet this is now we're gonna
shift gears a little bit because much of
the discussion of emergence in the
emergence literature uses examples like
either boxes of gas or human beings
either you know consciousness and human
beings or the relationship between
sociology and psychology and stuff like
that what I'm most interested in is
quantum mechanics and I think the
quantum mechanics is a crucially
important example to look at carefully
here how the classical world emerges
from the quantum world and I think that
most people don't do a very good job of
it so let's you know you've already
become experts on quantum mechanics now
you're an expert on emergence let's put
them together and dig a little bit more
deeply than you will usually get told so
let's look at the relationship of
quantum to classical mechanics which is
a relationship of emergence the
classical world emerges from the quantum
world that's try to fit it in to the
framework that we've already given and
there is a usual story so let me tell
you the usual story and how it falls
short a little bit okay the usual story
relies on you know when I say the usual
story I mean when you ever say as story
as usual it depends on what community of
people you're talking about I mean this
is what you usually find in textbooks
there are experts who have a more
sophisticated story than this but the
usual story invokes something called air
infests theorem paul ehrenfest creates
statistical and quantum physicists early
20th century friend with Einstein and
Bohr and things like that I once gave
the ehrenfest lecture at the University
of Leiden that doesn't make me so
special many people have given the
lecture but it's a fun thing to do and
he has a theorem that talks that is very
very important for the relationship of
the quantum world to the classical world
so he says consider a particle moving in
a potential so here is
position X and here's V of X okay so you
have a particle with a wave function
moving in this potential and he says
classically what are we trying to do
here we're trying to relate the quantum
description to the classical description
okay so let's first remember the
classical description well the time
derivative of the position is given by
the momentum over the mass and the time
derivative of the momentum is given by
minus the slope of the potential the
derivative the potential with respect to
X okay so you have some classical
particle it's gonna roll down the slope
in this case is going that way that's
the direction in which so the slope in
this case is negative so it pushes the
particle to the right okay good and we
would like to know well okay what
happens quantum mechanically that we can
derive this from we would like to see
the submerged we'd like to start with
the Schrodinger equation and derive this
classical behavior in some limit or
something right some situation anyway
so what do we do well there's already a
problem there's a huge problem let me
rearrange this to make it a little bit
more convenient the huge problem is the
ontology is completely different as
we've been emphasizing over and over
again in classical mechanics a particle
is a point in phase space it has a
position and it has a momentum those are
things that exist in quantum mechanics
the particle described by a wave
function right so in QM you have sigh of
X and T so for one thing P the momentum
doesn't even appear there as we talked
about way back when momentum has to do
with the wavelength of a wave you can
sort of convert from position space to
momentum space so I could say sigh of X
and T or what is sometimes called sight
tilde of p.m. T two equivalent ways you
can go back and forth between these one
fixes the other one
exactly and X and P in this in this
quantum world are not coordinates for
the particle they are observables
so this is what we tried to emphasize
that there's no answer to the question
in quantum mechanics what is the
position what is the momentum and that's
why the uncertainty principle is not a
statement about what you can measure
it's a statement about what the actual
observables how they relate to the
wavefunction there is no wave function
that is perfectly definitely defined as
a delta function in both position and
momentum so this is already kind of like
a conceptual problem how do we relate
these observables that are not
coordinates in a world where the
ontology is a vector in Hilbert space
two phase space to this X and P right
that are gonna have to have some
behavior that we would hope that would
look classical so what we can do
ehrenfest says or anyone says is we can
define expectation values so this is a
fancy way of saying if we were to
measure these observables the position
or the momentum if we were to start with
the same wave function and measure
position over and over again so when you
actually measure the position
wavefunction collapses so you have to
imagine that there is some way of
restarting the wave function exactly
where it was and you measure the
position again and again and again and
you find out what is the average okay
that's the expectation value so you
define X bar as a function of time so
you're not this is a little little bit
tricky to say you're not actually
measuring it you're saying
hypothetically were you to measure it
over and over again you can predict what
the outcome would be and find the
average of that that's what this is so
you're not actually disturbing it you're
letting the wave function smoothly
evolve and talking about how its
expectation value of all's so X of T can
be written as the integral of x times
the wave function over all possible X's
and likewise P of T for reasons that are
kind of complicated we're not going to
get into it's minus I times the
derivative of sine with respect to X
DX okay then that kind of makes some
sense right because the momentum has to
do with how quickly the wavefunction is
changing but anyway the point is that
there are equations right given the wave
function you can figure out the average
value and so now you have numbers right
before you just had a wave function a
vector in hilbert space by defining
these expectation values now you have
numbers it would be nice if these
numbers the expectation value of x and p
just obeyed these classical equations
wouldn't that be nice as the Beach Boys
once said well they don't but they come
very close and in the right
circumstances they kind of do so that's
how ehrenfest theorem works
so what ehrenfest says what he proves is
that the derivative of the expectation
value of x with respect to time rember
all we're trying to do is read arrive
these classical equations right here
Newton's laws turns out to be exactly
what you would want the expectation
value P divided by m that one worked but
what about the derivative of P bard
the expectation value of the momentum
well it turns out to be - take the
derivative of the potential with respect
to X and take its expectation value okay
so this thing here the thing in the bar
is the integral of DV DX times sine of X
DX so that looks pretty close like what
we wanted was so we had classically DP
DT is minus DV DX it would have been
nice to get DV d DP DT equals minus DV
DX bar right so in other words we were
hoping for this equals minus DV
evaluated at the average value of X DX
so in other words the difference between
these two things this and this is this
thing at the bottom which is what we
want says
go to the point which is the expectation
value of x the most likely place to see
the particle and ask what the slope of
the potential is that's what we want
that's what we want to be pushing around
the particle this thing at the top says
take all the different points of the
wavefunction sample them by asking what
is the slope with the potential there
okay and that's what gives you the
change of the expectation value of the
momentum but that's a quantity that has
no so if I have let's draw a picture
because this otherwise can be impossible
to understand
so here's V of X okay here's X here's
the potential that we drew and let me
draw a wave function let's imagine we
have a wave function that you know has
sort of different little parts to it so
this thing right here is saying you know
there's some slope here there's some
slope there there's some slope there at
all the different points where the wave
function has support there's some slope
to the potential average all of them
that's what ehrenfest theorem actually
says is relevant but you can see like
that's a completely irrelevant quantity
in Newtonian mechanics Newtonian
mechanics once you'd actually have the
slope of the potential where the
particle is and what you're coming
across is the fact that in quantum
mechanics there's no such thing as where
the particle is so it's a little bit
more difficult to interpret what's going
on I tend to dwell on this and be very
persnickety about exciting that people
get it wrong very easily but it's clear
what to do so what to do is consider
cases where the wave function is
localized near some particular location
okay so this kind of wave function just
makes no sense that's not going to work
for ehrenfest theorem which lock then
it's not going to give you classical
behavior according to ehrenfest theorem
but what if we were lucky enough to have
a situation where potential looks like
this and the wave function looks like
this okay then roughly speaking all that
matters is the value of the slope of the
potential near where the wavefunction is
peaked so we call this a wave packet a
wave packet something where it's nearly
localized in some particular place and
there's a formal mathematical way of
saying this it's the the idea is that
does the width of the wave packet has to
be small compared to the rate at which
the slope of the potential is changing
okay the second derivative of the
potential so there's a very
mathematically precise way of saying
your wave packet is localized enough to
pretend that it has one single location
and then you can show that - dv/dx
expectation value turns into - DV and X
bar DX and then you get the classical
limit back so that's then just a force
on the particle okay so what it's saying
here is that ehrenfest theorem gives you
classical motion for a quantum wave
function in certain circumstances
certain kinds of quantum wave functions
can behave classically and some can't
okay this kind of wave function has a
chance of behaving classically this is
in the classical limit this kind of wave
function up here just doesn't behave
classically at all so you have to be a
little bit careful about it so everyone
understands that you know sometimes they
they gloss over you know there's a
question why is the wave function ever
localized you have to answer that but
that that those can be answered there's
another thing though that is much more
subtle and interesting which is I mean
you know that when I localize a wave
function that means that I know - pretty
good precision what I will measure the
position to be which means that by the
uncertainty principle I don't know what
I'll measure the momentum to be now if
the thing that I'm talking about is a
big thing is the earth for example okay
I can know the position to pretty good
accuracy and the momentum to
good accuracy so this is where bigness
comes in you notice that no we're here
my discussion of ehrenfest theorem that
I say that the object was big wha
because ehrenfest theorem cares about
the wave packets being localized and
then you can say that the instantaneous
equation applies and gives you the
classical limit but if it spreads if
though if the wave packet spreads very
quickly then it no longer applies and so
ehrenfest theorem only gives you
classical behavior for a minute for a
second for a nanosecond but if the
particle is really really big and heavy
the spread in both position and momentum
can be small or position and velocity
can be small and in that case the
classical limit remains true but what
about the other case you know there are
cases where the momentum spreads where
the velocity a small variation in
velocity leads to a big difference like
for a single particle so like for a
single particle like an electron moving
through a bubble chamber when you see
that single track that looks pretty
classical mechanics the Arum an electron
is not at all heavy electrons light it
should spread out all over the place
something else is going on we know
what's going on we know the electron is
being observed it's wave function is
being measured repeatedly by the bubble
chamber and that leads to decoherence so
that's a clue as to what is going on so
not just electrons there exist big
classical systems like the earth the
earth is not an example but like the
earth that are actually the earth is an
example let me explain that that are
chaotic in their classical motions ok
what what chaos means sadly it's not a
whole big idea of video by itself but
the chaos phenomenon is the situation
where a small deviation in initial
conditions leads to a very large
typically exponential deviation in the
final place where the thing goes ok so
in many cases that's not true if you
drop two balls off a building and watch
them fall if you drop them as slightly
different times they will still land at
slightly different times chaotic
behavior happens when slight deviations
lead to huge deviations in
near future so I said the earth was not
that but it actually is but the time
scale for the chaotic behavior to show
up is really really long so the Earth's
orbit around the Sun is chaotic if you
give it a long enough time we can't
predict the position of all the planets
in the solar system to very high
precision a billion years in the future
because of this chaotic behavior but
there are systems that are much more
chaotic you know chaotic on a much
shorter timescale so there are my
favorite example is Saturn's moon
Hyperion Hyperion is a little lumpy
thing it's a very tiny moons it's a
captured asteroid that is a moon of
Saturn and it looks kind of like a
potato potato shaped and so this was
worked out a while ago the fact that
it's a lumpy thing so I don't know I'm
not gonna be able to draw it very well
Hyperion moon of Saturn okay it has
different moments of inertia
you know it's pulled and pushed by the
tidal forces in Saturn and the other
moons of Saturn and therefore it tumbles
okay so it I'm just gonna write tumbles
what I'm gonna do is I'll do this I'm
going to try to find a video of Hyperion
and I'm gonna try to put it into the
file that I published in this YouTube
video so we'll see if we can embed a
video a level of technological
sophistication I've never actually done
before but what you see when you look at
the video even if it's only in your
mind's eye is that Hyperion tumbles and
it tumbles chaotically because it's
being pushed and pulled by all these
other things in Saturn's orbit
Hyperion just sort of wobbles in an
unpredictable way so if you think that
Hyperion is really a quantum system it's
big you know it's it's heavier than you
are that's for sure
but a small deviation in its orientation
if you didn't know exactly how it was
oriented classically the classical
trajectories is quickly diverged you
can't predict what attitude what
orientation Hyperion is going to be in
if you translate that to the behavior of
the wave function for Hyperion what it
means is if you start Hyperion this
tumbling potato shaped moon of Saturn in
a wave function that is peaked around
some particular orientation
and rotational velocity that
wavefunction will quickly spread out
over all these different possibilities
so if all you thought about was the
wavefunction of Hyperion and he made a
prediction for what it is you know a
year later it should look like a blob
like a spherical cloud of probability it
should not look like a picture that you
can take we've taken pictures from NASA
the video I'm gonna show you is just a
simulation it's not really photographs
but it's based on photographs it looks
like there is a planet there with a real
a moon an asteroid of former asteroid
that is now a moon with an actual
position and location like classical
things should have why does it look
classical to us ehrenfest theorem does
not give you the answer the wave packet
of the orientation of Hyperion is
chaotic and should spread out over a
short time scale the answer is D
coherence of course is the same answers
for the electron the point is that
Hyperion is in the solar system it is
constantly being bombarded by photons
for example as well as by other things
and they're essentially branching the
wave function of the universe or if you
like they are measuring the wave
function of Hyperion all the time and so
what that means is that there is an
effective emergent description of what
Hyperion is doing that is classical but
not deterministically classical so what
you get is a stochastic classical
dynamics so this combination of quantum
mechanics and chaos theory is saying
that not only if you didn't measure the
state of Hyperion exactly would it be
unpredictable it's saying it is
unpredictable measure it all you want
because you can't put its wavefunction
into a state where it won't spread out
and then be observed and be branched in
different ways by the environment around
it ok so there's still classical
behavior in a quantumly chaotic system
but it's a little bit more subtle you
got to think a little bit more about how
it gets there and you can't just look at
the system itself you have to include
the environment and decoherence and so
forth ok I see an hour has gone by two
more things I want to tell you one is
kind of kind of a stretch but that's ok
you're very much smarter and well
informed now than you than where you
were 20 videos ago or whatever it was
when we started this whole series I want
to tell you about the fact that because
now that we understand emergence and now
we understand how you know classical
physics relates to quantum physics so
we've gone both ways that's let's pause
and say that when we first did quantum
mechanics we emphasized that the typical
way that you made a quantum mechanical
theory was to start with a classical
theory and quantize it and we said look
nature probably doesn't do that I mean
nature probably is quanta from the start
but nevertheless that's the way we do it
and what we've just done is to remind
you that you can go the other way as
well you can start with the quantum
mechanical theory and get a classical
behavior from it in the right
circumstances so the domain of
applicability of that classical theory
will be smaller than the domain of the
quantum theory but that's ok what I want
to do now is mention the fact that this
going back and forth is not unique ok
there is no rule that says that given a
quantum theory there is only one
classical theory you can get from it or
the other way around
given a classical theory you can
quantize it and that is non uniqueness
both ways given a classical theory you
can quantize it in different ways this
is a well-known thing operator operator
ordering ambiguities people talk about
not that interesting to be honest more
interesting is
there are two different classical
theories that you can quantize and get
the same quantum theory two very
different classical theories and this is
just so mine stretchy mind-boggling and
weird that I even though it's beyond
what we're normally doing here and the
greatest ideas I have to explain it to
you so let me give you an example let me
say say what I'm giving you an example
of one quantum theory can arise by
quantizing two or maybe more different
come on spell different classical
theories just blew my mind anyway when I
first was shown this example in grad
school so here's the example again not
something you will normally be told and
pop physics discussions but that's okay
this is something called the sign Gordon
theory the klein-gordon theory
you may remember it's just a theory of a
scalar field just you know doing
whatever it wants a scalar field with
some potential V of I so scalar field
Phi potential V of Phi and Sidney
Coleman my old quantum field theory
professor from grad school wrote a paper
about a particular theory klein-gordon
theory where you took the potential to
be looking like the sine of Phi so a
potential that went up and down so you
have Phi V of Phi and then the potential
looks like this okay so as a joke he
called it the sine Gordon theory and
sadly everyone loved that name and he
was very chagrin he was slightly
embarrassed that people love that name
they kept it but that's what we call it
now the sine Gordon theory okay
and in particular so I went so this is
just a theory of a scalar field with
this kind of potential that's that's
what it is
and in particular let's look at it in 1
plus 1 dimensions so 1 plus 1
to still true but we're talking about we
say one plus one clean one dimension of
space one dimension of time so we have a
line that evolves with time and there's
a scalar field moving around wiggling in
this particular potential so usually it
wants to wiggle near the bottom of the
potential but sometimes maybe it'll hop
over the top you know depending on
what's happening okay so basically there
are two things that I'll just say what I
just said again there are two things
that can happen there can be like small
oscillations near the bottom and in the
quantum theory those would just show up
as particles right scalar bosons spin
zero particles but then there are also
configurations that go from one minimum
to another right and we might remember
we talked a little bit about that idea
and we talked about topology because
this is a topological defect known as a
domain wall if you have two different
minimum points of the vacuum two
different vacua two different minimum
points of the potential that the field
is in one of them over here one of them
over here then in between there needs to
be energy when the field climbs over the
potential to get there so in one plus
one dimensions you can plot that right
so here's X now this is um here
in this plot Phi was the horizontal axis
now Phi is the vertical axis and X is
the vertical axis X is the horizontal
axis so I can imagine a situation where
Phi is let's say if I continued this
down right so here's a minimum there's a
minimum there's a situation where Phi is
in 1 minimum and then as sort of quickly
goes up to the next minimum so if this
is call it minus V and plus V this is
minus V and plus V okay and this is for
unfortunate historical reasons called
the kink solution get all of your kinky
jokes out of the way right now but it
you can see it's sort of a kink in the
field that goes up and it goes down so
there you go so this is a theory that
has both particles sitting zlatan the
potential and it has these domain walls
kinks
Solutions okay I mean generally you
would have both here is the here is the
miracle these small oscillations as we
said they're just scalar bosons they're
pretty typical if you look at the bottom
of a sign potential or a cosine
potential or whatever I think we even
mentioned the fact that it looks kind of
like a parabola so it kind of looks like
a simple harmonic oscillator so it kind
of looks like ordinary things we've
already quantized and talked about
ordinary scalar bosons with different
masses as long as the oscillations are
very tiny compared to the variation of
potential but there's also these kinks
and these kinks themselves are kind of
particle like you know if we were in
three dimensions than a domain wall is a
big thing that stretches across the
universe but if you're on a line right
if you only have one dimension of space
then a particle is just something is
located at one point in space and this
kink is also kind of located at one
point in space right I put it here at
zero but I could have put it anywhere in
fact it can even you know I could expand
this a little bit you take this picture
over here I could let space go on a bit
here and I could imagine a configuration
that stayed in this vacuum and then it
went back down to the other vacuum right
so this would be if this is a kink over
here this is an anti kink going the
other way so you could have a series of
kinks and anti kinks and then go up and
down again get all the jokes out of your
system and when a king can tie kink hit
each other they annihilate right they go
away because you can just flop over so
this whole situation over time can
evolve into something with just has some
vibrations then goes like that right the
kink and the anti kink can just
annihilate so all those words the kink
solution looks like a particle
especially if you know the parameters
the potential are such that it's very
thin it kind of looks like a particle it
has a position as a velocity and a kink
has anti kinks and they can annihilate
make some sound like particles in fact
makes them sound like fermions doesn't
it makes them sound kind of like
electrons you know there's particles and
antiparticles and they could annihilate
right so what's Coleman showed in his
paper is that there is another theory of
fermions that is a classical Lagrangian
you can write down with the feature that
when you quantize it you get exactly the
same theory as when you quantize the
sign Gordon theory so that fermion
theory is called the massive Turing
model I'm not gonna go into details here
but it's a specific model of fermions
I've got a letter mister Turing's name
it's a specific theory of fermions and
anti fermions in 1 dimensional space
okay that's what it is you can write
down it has a Lagrangian etc and so then
you can compare the sign Gordon theory
to the massive Turing theory and in the
sign gourd there you have scalar bosons
and you have domain walls or kinks in
the masseter in theory you have fermions
because that's what you put in the
fundamental degrees of freedom or
fermions but you know if you take an
electron and a proton two fermions put
them together to make a hydrogen atom
the hydrogen atom has spin zero or spin
one depending on how the spins align
right so the hydrogen atom is a boson
it's made of two spin 1/2 particles and
you get either a spin 0 or spin 1
combination depending on whether they're
aligned or anti aligned so you can and
that's a generic fact you can take two
spin 1/2 fermions and if they bind
together you could make a spin zero or
other spin boson bound States of
fermions or bosons so you get boson ik
bound States
and what Coleman was able to do was show
that these theories are exactly the same
at the quantum mechanical level the
scalar bosons in the sign Gordon Theory
map on to the bound states of Fermi on
anti Fermi on in the mass of Turing
model and the domain walls and the sign
Gordon Theory map on to the fundamental
fermions in the massive Turing Theory
domain walls the son Gordon theory upon
the fundamental fermions the message
during theory so I'm not gonna go to the
details here obviously you can look up
papers there's this whole idea this is a
broader idea called boson ization in 1
plus 1 dimensional field theories it
very often is the case that you can
describe things using fermions or they
bind up into bosons so again the claim
I'll just repeat the claim I can write
down all the gironjin
in 1 plus 1 dimensions for a scalar
field with a sinusoidal potential the
sign Gordon theory I can write down a
completely different-looking lagrangian
for a Fermi on in 1 plus 1 dimension
that interacts with itself in certain
ways as an anti particle the massive
Turing model and then I can do quantum
mechanics I can quantize both
lagrangians
and I can show that both theories are
secretly exactly the same quantum theory
so two different classical theories
giving rise to the same quantum
mechanical theory and not just you know
some different parameters or some
different labels one is a theory of
bosons the other there's a theory of
fermions so the point of this is if you
were to say given this quantum
mechanical theory what is it really
given the quantum mechanical theory
which is just some Hamiltonian operator
acting on Hilbert space given that is
this really a theory of bosons or is
this really a theory of fermions the
answer is there's no answer there's no
answer to that question this description
that you made up in terms of bosons and
fermions there's a classical language
and then you quantize the theory to get
the real true theory which is the
quantum theory and there's more than one
classical theory that you can quantize
to get this quantum theory so the answer
is what is it really what is the true
fundamental stuff that we're talking
about here is not a question that has an
answer all this talk about bosons and
fermions
which is the theory really made of and
which are just the emergent ones that's
not an answerable question in in this
particular model good if you like that
you're gonna love the next example of
the same thing which is something you
maybe have heard of which is the ad SC
ft correspondence so my point in showing
you the sign Gordon terney model
correspondence was to say we can
quantize two theories one is fermions
one is bosons show they're really the
same theory okay so you don't need to
start from the same starting point to
make a quantum theory that is really the
same that the classical starting points
can be very different
the ad se of T correspondence is an
example where you start with two
different theories in two different
dimensional space times and you get the
same quantum theory at least we think
you do or at least if you do in certain
regimes and where the details are a
little bit much less clear here because
gravity is involved here but that's why
it's exciting as well as why it's
incompletely understood so ad s is anti
de sitter space which is a solution to
Einstein's equations with a cosmological
constant lambda the vacuum energy the
energy of empty space less than zero a
negative value for the cosmos real
constant so this is a cosmological
solution with nothing else in it so no
particles no radiation just empty space
with nothing but negative vacuum energy
de sitter space is the solution you get
with nothing but positive vacuum energy
so this is anti de sitter space and CFT
means conformal field theory
so in conformal field theory is just an
example of quantum field theory
conformal though means that it is
completely scale free there are no
parameters in the theory that pick out a
certain length scale so if you for
example have any particles that have a
mass then you do not have a conformal
field theory because a mass for a
particle picks out a Compton wavelength
and that's a length scale conformal
field theory looks exactly the same at
every length scale if you want to you
know
QED quantum electromagnetism at very
very very low energies well below the
energy of the electrons you're really
nothing but photons interacting with
each other that's almost a conformal
field theory it's not quite because of
details because the electrons are kind
of still there in some sense but it
could form what the field theory is
really exactly the same at all scales so
it's kind of a weird kind of field
theory but the conformal field theory
does not have gravity so the conformal
field theory we're talking about here is
just a quantum field theory it's
perfectly well defined you can write
down the Lagrangian you can quantize it
you can do all the quantum field theory
you want the anti-de sitter theory we're
talking about here is gravity in fact
super gravity in fact string theory on
anti-de sitter space so that's much less
well-defined you know we have some ideas
about what that is like but this is a
true the idea is the claim the hope the
aspiration is that this is a true theory
of quantum gravity in certain background
so what we know how to do is look at
small deviations look at particles or
even black holes in that background but
it is not you know some people complain
because it's not a completely background
independent theory and that's a fair
complaint this is a theory where at
least the boundary conditions are those
of anti-de sitter space so what is the
relationship between these two theories
the relationship is the following
remember we were drawing pictures and we
talked about gravity we do different
pictures of the Kruskal diagram for the
black hole Kruskal diagram has this nice
property that light cones are always at
45 degrees so that's a step along the
way to a more elaborate thing called a
Penrose diagram or a Carter Penrose
diagram Brandon Carter and Roger Penrose
invented a way to draw a whole space
times even if they're infinitely big
draw them in a finally piece of paper so
here's the Penrose diagram for anti-de
sitter space it looks like a cylinder
and it has the property I said finite
piece of paper I know but in this
picture time goes up eternally and space
is the interior here
and space is finite sorry
space is infinite anti-de sitter space
is an open universe that goes on forever
but I've drawn it in such a way such
that it fits into this disk here okay
I've contracted it like that
so this interior of the cylinder is
anti-de sitter space okay and it has a
boundary has a boundary that looks like
a cylinder like the edge of a cylinder
right and so the this was first done by
Juan maldacena in 1996 maybe something
like that 97 98 around there you know I
was a postdoc at the time and what Malda
saying it was studying was abs in let's
say 4 plus 1 dimensions don't ask why
but there's good string theory reasons
why that was a logical thing to study so
the boundary of abs is this cylinder it
looks like it's a circle times time but
the circle is infinitely big
so it's really just flat ok if you take
a circle or a sphere and make it bigger
and bigger it looks locally flatter and
flatter so this is literally an
infinitely big sphere which is the
equivalent to flat space-time and the
boundary then is 3 plus 1 dimensional
and you can define a conformal field
theory on it so in other words you have
two different space times you have the
space-time inside which is a five
dimensional anti-de sitter space and you
can define gravity on that you can have
gravity and other forces of nature
strings and other things that would
appear in super gravity so you can do
quantum gravity and five dimensional
anti-de sitter space then you can also
completely separately have a theory a
quantum field theory a conformal field
theory without gravity on the boundary
okay which is one dimension lower in
this case is three plus one dimensional
and what mala Sina says is that these
two theories are the same these two
classical languages the
language of conformal fields moving in
flat space-time of four dimensions total
and this other classical language of
gravity in five dimensional space-time
with anti-de sitter boundary conditions
they are two different ways of talking
about the same quantum mechanical theory
this is called a duality between these
two descriptions the sign Gordon
necessary models also call the duality
you can think of a duality is two
different classical versions of the same
quantum mechanical theory and I can't do
much I can't do much about the details
of anti-de sitter space and the
conformal field theory but the point is
I just try to drive home how true it is
when I say that nature works as a
quantum mechanical theory and every time
we talk about a classical theory that's
just convenient to us okay this example
was two different classical theories one
bosons one fermions but they're just
secretly two different ways of talking
about the same quantum theory this is
two different theories one with gravity
in five dimensions and one without
gravity in four dimensions and again the
same theory you might say well there
must be more degrees of freedom in five
dimensions than four dimensions but
that's not true because in both cases
there is an infinite number of degrees
of freedom and infinity is still
infinity infinity times infinity is
infinity and this is you know the the
most most obvious beloved manifestation
of the holographic principle the
holographic principle being the idea
that in a black hole or other places
where you have a horizon or gravity is
important you can encode all the
information about space-time in one
lower dimension on the horizon of a
black hole or something like that
here you're encoding all the information
about the five dimensional anti-de
sitter space in the four-dimensional
boundary you can you can there's a
dictionary it's not perfect again you
know we don't know as much about this as
we want but we tested to the conjecture
and it's very very strongly supported so
we believe that any question you can ask
in that five dimensional anti-de sitter
space can be answered in terms of a
question asked from the four-dimensional
theory and these days there's a very say
the words I'm not gonna explain anything
at all it's a very exciting idea called
entanglement wedge reconstruction
dispute about buzzwords here and
basically this is an approach to
thinking about black holes in anti-de
sitter space evaporating so remember I
told you about the black hole
information loss problem here's an
example in this anti de sitter space and
for in five dimensions well I could make
a black hole there because gravity
exists in this theory and I could let it
evaporate and I just promised you that
any question I asked in anti-de sitter
space quantum gravity should be
answerable in the boundary conformal
field theory where gravity does not
exist and all of the obstacles to
understanding quantum gravity are
irrelevant so I should be able to make a
black hole watch it evaporate and ask
what happened from the point of view of
the boundary so people have been trying
to do that now for over 20 years and the
problem is yes you can do that but
actually seeing how the information gets
out has eluded us so far so this
approach of entanglement wedge
reconstruction seems to be a set of
clues about how the information can get
out of black holes in this case not
something to talk about right here but
you know maybe a future podcast I'll try
to get into this anyway we yet again
another way of saying quantum mechanics
is what the world is made of classical
physics can emerge in different ways the
CFT and the 80s theory are two different
emergent descriptions of the same
underlying quantum theory okay final
topic which is completely different now
for something completely different
about emergence is weak versus strong
emergence all right this is nothing to
do with quantum mechanics even
fundamental physics really but maybe it
does and I alluded to this idea earlier
this idea of when the macroscopic theory
emerges is there a sense in which in
principle and Laplace is demon type
fashion you could figure out what was
going on from the point of
a microscopic theory so that's weak
emergence if you believe that that is
possible
so we mean we don't mean like it's less
strong or powerful we mean it's a it's a
weaker notion it's claiming less okay
weak emergence strong emergence is
something a more radical claim that's
what it means to be strong in this case
so in weak emergence the macro theory is
let's call it autonomous which means to
say within the macro theory the theory
of gases or whatever I can ask questions
I can answer them without knowing what
is going on in the micro Theory that's
the sense in which it is autonomous but
it can be simulated exactly by the micro
theory
so in principle you're saying I have
some box of gas I'm going to predict
what it's gonna do next but you're also
saying that if I knew exactly what the
phase phase point was for all the atoms
and particles in the box and I knew all
the microscopic laws of physics I could
put that on a computer figure out what
would happen next and I could also
derive what would happen to the box of
gas okay so in other words in weak
emergence you imagine that there is some
micro theory and the micro theory has a
lot of different states right there's a
lot of different this is not space I'm
drawing here this is the space of states
in the microscopic theory whatever that
might be may be wave functions or
whatever and then there's a map from
that micro theory to the macro theory
and let's imagine this is a sort of
coarse graining situation so there are
fewer states in the macro theory and the
claim of weak emergence is that given
some particular state in the micro
theory I can literally map it to a state
to the macro theory I can also evolve it
in time right to a different state I
don't know what it does it goes up here
and it many many many states once again
and the laws of physics in the micro
world give me what microstate it goes to
and I can play the same game in the
macro theory I can show that this goes
to some other macro state and the point
is that there still is a map from the
micro theory to the macro theory and
this diagram commutes as we say in the
math literature in other words starting
from this microstate to drift different
colors you can follow it you can either
go to the macro theory and then evolve
it or you could evolve it and then go to
the macro theory and you get the same
answer right that's what it means to
have weak emergence you can evolve the
macro theory but you could also equally
well evolve in the micro theory strong
emergence which let me just tell you I
don't think exists but people talk about
it so I feel like I should mention it
strong emergence says no you can't
in other words strong emergence is the
idea that there is a micro theory and
there is a macro theory but the macro
theory even if it looks like the macro
theory is describing a large collection
of micro things the rules of the game
are fundamentally different in the macro
theory they are not reducible they are
not simulated on a computer there's
something that is truly new that it's
coming out in the macro realm in fact in
many social sciences that's the way this
particular word emergence is usually
used if you if you google the British
emergentist s-- you will find a whole
bunch of people who say exactly this
that you know you can't reduce what
happens in large groups of people to
small numbers of people so the
collective behavior thereof there's some
fundamentally new non simulated thing
and that's what strong emergence would
be about so I don't believe that
actually happens in the world but I do
want to say that it could you know I
want to be open to the possibility so
what would that mean in the language
that we previously talked about what it
means is something like this like here's
reality
what it means is basically so here's why
I don't believe it because let's say
that you're thinking like a physicist
and your micro theory is the standard
model of particle physics or the core
theory so we can include gravity there's
a Lagrangian right there's an equation
for the standard model plus gravity and
like it or not for any given
wavefunction you plug it in in that
Lagrangian or in the Schrodinger
equation you convert to a Hamiltonian it
will tell you how that wave function
evolves uniquely there's no ambiguity
there so if you make the strong
emergence claim if you say that in
principle the behavior of a human being
let's say cannot be reduced to the
behavior of the atoms and molecules and
forces that make up that human being
you're saying the lagrangian of the
standard model must be wrong you can't
say it's completely right and never
violated but it's insufficient to
predict what is going to happen for a
human being those two statements are
incompatible with each other and it's
very very hard to imagine the ways in
which you would violate the lagrangian
for the standard model macroscopically
but not microscopically okay I mean you
can say the words but no one has ever
come close to writing down equations or
actually giving a principled suggestion
for what the new laws of physics would
be that's why it's very hard and in some
sense the reason why it's very hard is
this idea that we have of locality right
I mean it's built into the framework of
the standard model that the world is a
quantum field theory and quantum fields
exist at different points quantum wave
function has entanglement between
different points but the fields that
you're entangling exist at various
points and they interact at the same
point in space we talked about this many
videos ago in the force and action and
energy video locality is really the
underlying thing that makes quantum
field theory go and what you need to do
if you want to believe in strong
emergence is to give up on that locality
in some fundamental way you need to give
up on the idea that not only are the
laws different but
to give up on the idea of sorry not only
that was the same but there's it's even
correct to think about a human being as
just a collection of electrons and
protons and neutrons so the way I would
do it in terms of the pictures I drew
before is you have reality you have our
micro Theory which might be the core
theory the standard model and then you
have some macro theory which is your
favorite theory of I don't know
consciousness or whatever and the claim
is that the macro theory is not a subset
of the micro theory so there is a domain
of applicability for the micro theory
and there's a domain vac ability for the
macro theory that looks like this right
so there's a whole part of reality which
is described by the macro theory but is
not described by the micro theory that's
when strong emergence is conceivable so
you're saying that sure if I look at
what happens to one electron bumping
into some small number of other
electrons then the standard model
describes it perfectly but once it's
surrounded by Avogadro's number of
electrons then the standard model fails
to describe it that is outside the realm
of validity of applicability of the
theory there's no reason I think in
fundamental physics to suspect that
anything like that actually happens the
only reason is you know I think that the
the advocates for this would say well
they want to understand consciousness
and they don't think the consciousness
is explicable in terms of what happens
in the standard model of particle
physics I think it is your opinion may
differ but I'm offering this as a peace
offering to people who actually believe
in strong emergence I think they should
be more clear about what it could
possibly mean I think this is what it
could possibly mean if you could try to
make it work quantitatively in terms of
equations and so forth good for you that
would be a huge progress I don't think
it's the way to go but you know
emergence is murky there's probably a
lot that we have yet to learn